mr speaker of course i want to renew my  uh well my apologies and uh and  sympathies for all those who lost uh  loved ones uh during the pandemic uh  people who uh who lost loved ones in in  care homes  and i want to remind the house of how of  what an incredibly difficult time that  was and how difficult that decision was  and there were there were very we didn't  know very much about the disease and the  point i was trying to make to which she  refers is the thing that we didn't know  in particular uh mr speaker uh was uh  that coveted could be transmitted  asymptomatically  in the way that it was and uh and that  was something that i wish we had known  more about uh at the time as for the  ruling that she mentions we will study  it and  we will of course respond further in due  course